here lies the universe it lived a great
life full of energy and excitement but
sadly all things come to an end
or do they hey crazies I wanted to
finish off our cosmology series properly
with a density mover that death will
happen in the very distant future but
how that will go down depends heavily on
the past and the present let's start
with the present first we need a number
that can tell us how big the universe
has grown and that can be tricky if the
universe is infinite we know the
observable universe is 93 billion light
years across
but since the cosmic horizon can grow at
a different rate than the universe
expands that bubble doesn't always
contain the same amount of stuff we need
something a little more useful the
observable universe contains about 10
million super clusters that means the
average distance between super clusters
is currently about 400 million
light-years so anything we come up with
for our universe better at least match
that yes but there weren't always
galaxies in the past and there might not
always be galaxies in your future hmm
you're right
average super cluster distance is great
as long as there are super clusters but
we don't know if there will be when the
universe dies
what we need is something a little more
generic let's do this the easy way and
just label the present day one when the
universe is smaller this scale will be
less than one when the universe is
bigger this scale will be greater than
one wait a minute that's just the scale
factor from the flower metric huh it's
neat how this all fit together the fact
that we even get to use a metric that
simple is because the universe is
mind-blowing ly uniform on the large
scale our world isn't uniform it's part
of what makes it interesting the same
can be said for the scale of planets
stars galaxies or even clusters of
galaxies but on the grand scale those
are insignificant details the universe
is simple okay to make any kind of
prediction about the future we need a
pattern for how that scale factor is
changing in other words we need to know
what the past looks like so we can
figure out what the future looks like
here's what we need the flower metrics
find signs of
Asians yes more than one there are
technically ten matter density that's
both regular and dark matter dark energy
density and special curvature if we take
what we know from the metric and toss it
into Einstein's equations we get
something called the Freedman equation
named after Russian physicist Alexander
Friedmann
as you can see regular matter adds to
the curvature of space and slows down
the expansion dark energy also adds to
the curvature of space but speeds up the
expansion these two equations describe
all possible futures for the universe so
the moment you've been waiting for here
are the options there's the Big Crunch
where the universe eventually Rika
lapses that's closely related to my
personal favorite the cyclic universe
where the universe expands and collapses
over and over again in a Big Bounce
there's the big freeze or the heat death
where the expansion could slow down or
speed up but it never stops so the
universe expands forever
then there's the big rip the most
extreme possible future where the
universe accelerates so quickly that the
scale factor becomes infinite in a
finite amount of time the universe rips
itself into infinitely small pieces
which one is our universe that's a great
question thankfully a lot of scientists
have already done the hard work of
measuring these numbers for us our
universe appears to be this one it
started accelerating in its expansion
about six billion years ago but it's not
accelerating fast enough to rip itself
to this we have a heat death to look
forward to at which point you might be
wondering what's the heat death exactly
what it sounds like right now we live in
a time of complexity there are trillions
of galaxies each filled with hundreds of
billions of stars many of those stars
have orbiting planets and at least one
of those planets as a living ecosystem
more time to be alive but it won't
always be this way trillions of years
from now all the stars will burn out
leaving behind cold corpses eventually
all black holes will evaporate through
Hawking radiation after that matter and
photons just continue spreading out as
the universe expands one day every
particle will be so far apart that
nothing happens in
that's a heat death missile literally
the upside is it's not supposed to
happen for at least in other Google
years so you'll all be long gone by then
says if the false vacuum collapse
doesn't consume its first nightmare fuel
so which ended the University you like
that I'll include some of your answers
in the next comment response video where
we'll go over a bunch of comments from
this entire series thanks for liking and
sharing this video don't forget to
subscribe if you'd like to keep up with
us and until next time remember it's
okay to be a little crazy
[Music]